here's something really weird that I
want your help with it and by you I mean
listeners and viewers in the past
outside my apartment here in Boston I've
heard noises that very clearly are two
cats I generally know what cats sound
like even though as we've made very very
clear in the last couple weeks I'm not
at all cat guy uh I I sort of know what
cats generally sound like and a couple
times I've opened up my back window or
sliding door and heard what what were
clearly cats somewhere between fifty and
a hundred feet away the other day I
heard a noise that was so wretched and
so disturbing that I believe was also an
animal noise I don't know if what I'm
about to play for you which I recorded
is sound of the sound of an animal of
some kind being abused we're gonna
listen to it closely uh Rachel I don't
believe you've heard this Pat you've
heard part of it we're gonna listen to
it closely maybe it's super obvious what
animal this is or what's going on let's
take a listen and see if we can figure
out what was going on outside my
apartment
[Music]
yeah it sounds to me like flipper the
dolphin but I mean I don't think it's a
dolphin I I live a couple of miles from
from the beach uh does it on the first
pass does anybody have an idea what that
noise might be anybody um I mean I don't
think a dolphin was able to make its way
miles inland out and then only then
started to suffocate any I mean could
this be maybe a bird that's injured
Rachel it does sound like a bird you
live in Boston right I do I do okay it's
a strange noise it's the noise you might
associate more with you know a safari
made right another continent let's
listen to it one more time now this time
I want you to listen to one thing in
particular about in the middle I think
that there might be some human voices
which is what made me think maybe
there's someone in the brush or bushes
or trees behind my place that was doing
something to an animal let's listen as
closely as we can here
[Music]
did you hear that very squeaky there was
a moment there where it sounded like
there were people talking anyway I have
no idea what's going on the person
talking was probably Alex Jones yeah I'm
sure was Alex Jones uh but behind my
apartment I have no idea and maybe none
of us are our skilled enough or
knowledgeable knowledgeable enough about
animals to know maybe there's a really
obvious answer to what that is but I
don't know what it is I'm sure all the
viewers are gonna come to us and say
this obviously this animals how I guys
not know that it was obviously a baby
seal two miles inland in a part of the
world where you would not expect to
necessarily see one actually are there
there are some seals in uh oh yeah New
England right now okay all right well
clearly we're clearly we know a ton
about animals all right let's uh let's
leave it there and see what kind of
feedback we get